[Music]
assalamualaikum this is asadullah ali of
the andalusian project coming at you
today with a response video
um
and to be frank i couldn't help myself
i i promised myself i wouldn't respond
to this individual again especially
after i just responded to them
in my last i jihad episode but um i
really couldn't help myself because i
felt that this would
you know this was a perfect case study
for something that i've wanted to point
out for quite some time
but prior to getting into that um
i just want you guys to notice my
awesome little mug here
uh
which is from the movie princess bride i
don't know if you're familiar with that
movie but it's a great family uh fantasy
flick um
part romance you know part fantasy
park humor it's a movie that doesn't
take itself very seriously but i
recommend it to everyone who
who uh you know wants to watch a
family-friendly film
a classic that's derived from a a famous
novel
um and the quote here is from one of the
characters in the movie one of my
favorite characters enigo mandoya who's
a spanish uh sword fighter trying to
avenge his father
uh
anyways this is one of my favorite
movies of all time
and like i said i recommend it
so
getting into the subject matter
the apostate prophet
posted a video a few days ago
basically the title was
twitter assist islamist that was the
actual title twitter assist islamist and
in that video he was complaining about
being suspended from twitter permanently
uh for posting a particular tweet
and that tweet was essentially
um him arguing or claiming that islam
you know
uh promotes the death of apostates and
critics etc etc and he posted it in
response to a another twitter user and
we'll get into the context of the
discussion more a little later
and uh in in that entire video he just
goes on this huge rant where he
basically
tries to argue that his free speech has
been stifled and
you know he he makes basically makes
this huge call to action where
uh arguing that you know twitter is is
not abiding by free speech and the
principles of western democracy etc etc
and um
[Music]
there's a lot in there
that needs to be deconstructed but but
essentially what i found in it was quite
interesting in that it's the same script
that you hear from every single popular
islamophobe and ex-muslim online
and i mean that
deliberately i don't i don't think this
is exaggeration at all
and there seems to be this script that's
passed around
i'm not saying it's a real script but
it's just that the same points are used
every single time that an islamophobe or
an ex-muslim is
is banned from a social media website
they always make the same points and
they always
they always make it seem like they're
being persecuted and that there's this
huge conspiracy against them
and
i like to call it the three-step program
for those with a martyr complex and for
those of you who watched my previous
video you'll know i talked about martyr
complexes a little bit with especially
with regards to
those who like to post uh videos about
hate getting you know receiving hate
comments
but in the same vein um a lot of these
ex-muslims and islamophobes love to play
this little
you know uh
martyr
uh
like to have this little martyr complex
whenever they're banned from social
media and they come up with all these
ridiculous excuses
so i just want to go over them real
quick to showcase the irrationality and
in the self-delusion of a lot of these
individuals uh just so you know just how
ridiculous
these people can be
and and how
and how their views
not only affect their understanding of
islam but of reality in general and i
think this will be helpful for future
videos so you guys understand the sort
of mentality that i'm debating against
and as i said in the previous video
not everyone who criticizes islam is
necessarily
like this but this is among the popular
islamophobes popular ex-muslims on
social media they tend to have very
similar mentalities and personalities
when it comes to
um
things that happen to them whenever they
whenever they're reacting to certain
things
so anyways um
for some background uh he was banned for
this tweet
he says in this video
so today i woke up and the first thing i
noticed when i looked at my phone was
that i received an email from twitter
your twitter account has been suspended
of course i wondered what i have done
and for how long they have suspended me
so i started reading the email
hello apostate prophet hello your
account ex-muslim prophet has been
suspended for violating the twitter
rules specifically for violating our
rules against hateful conduct
you may not promote violence against
threaten or harass other people on the
basis of race ethnicity national origin
sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease
okay i did not so i looked at what tweet
they cited as reason and that was this
tweet in which i said islam orders the
killing of apostates adulterers gays
heretics critics of islam and so on
islam orders to spread the religion by
the sword and explicitly insults
non-believers in the quran but islam
forbids the killing of spiders therefore
islam is peace this is an obvious
mockery of the logic that i found in the
tweet that i retweeted which says
growing up in a muslim household i
wasn't even allowed to kill a spider
because it's a sin and people still go
around saying islam promotes violence
hmm
i have been banned permanently from
twitter for this
are you kidding me in my tweet i
basically said that islam orders the
killing of apostates adulterers case
heretics and so on and how violent and
brutal islam is and i mocked islam i
mocked the logic of people defending
islam and i am being banned for hateful
conduct for which the explanation is
promote violence against threaten or
harass other people based on whatever
group sorry i don't know who these
moderators at twitter are who moderate
these tweets apparently they can't read
but i am not the one inciting violence
or harassment or hate or anything at all
i am the one pointing out that an
ideology a religion promotes these ideas
and i am against those ideas i criticize
it for that i am a former muslim i
criticize my former religion because of
these qualities how am i involved in
hateful conduct here i still want to be
naive and want to assume that this was
just a big misunderstanding because how
can this be any normal person would look
at this and see that i am not the one
inciting violence or hate or whatever it
is twitter seems to be very confused
about who they ban for what they ban
people because if they banned me for
this
if they banned me for hateful conduct
because i used words that islam orders
then they should have banned people like
like this guy for example this sheikh
from saudi arabia who clearly said in a
tweet before that apostasy is a crime
and that apostates need to be tried and
convicted and executed that they are
hypocrites this is still on twitter and
this was posted almost a year ago it has
been reported but twitter has done
nothing
and now you know he's outraged he is so
outraged by this and all of his
followers on twitter are are calling for
twitter to to reinstate his account and
and oh it's such a it's a horrendous
atrocity you know this just occurred i
mean i mean how dare you
ban me
you know i'm immune from being banned
um
so i'm gonna go over the
the three steps
the the three excuses that these um
these individuals love to give
um so let's start with number one
this uh
this claim of being innocent
this claim that i was just stating facts
that's step number one stating that i
was just you know
you know stating facts i didn't say
anything i wasn't harassing anyone i was
just stating facts
and in his video he points out that
there's a double standard with twitter
because apparently the saudi sheikh by
the name of assam ala hakeem
who was answering one of his followers
questions about the punishment for
apostasy in islamic state
he wasn't banned for saying that islam
states that an apostate should be killed
he wasn't banned for stating his opinion
about this
but apostate prophet was banned for
stating the facts so there must be a
double standard
of course there is a significant
difference between
what assam al-hakim was saying
and what the apostate prophet was saying
and you're probably wondering what could
that be well it has a little bit to do
with something called tone
okay
and i know a lot of you out there
might not understand this so let me try
to explain something before i go into
detail about the differences between
these two things these two tweets
imagine for an ins for for a moment just
imagine for a moment that i was at a
conference
an academic conference where i was
talking about
how to resolve structural racism in
society like american society and i
pointed out the fact that african
americans are disproportionately
represented in the prison population
now at that conference where i'm trying
to resolve the issue of structural
racism
nobody would probably probably no one
i'd gather zero people would
interpret my comment in a racist manner
or interpret my comment as harassment
because i'm just stating a fact that i
want to resolve
but then imagine a different scenario
where i'm at a gas station or something
and i get into a verbal altercation with
an african-american individual
and during this altercation it gets very
heated and i decide to respond in an
aggressive manner
and i yell at this person and i say you
know what
african americans are disproportionately
represented in the prison population
now
any spectator viewing that
argument
would probably not take that comment in
a neutral way nor would the
african-american individual that i'm
speaking with
um they probably would take it in a very
disparaging manner
in a way
in a very racist manner
and they would probably accuse me of
racism and i think rightfully so
even though i stated the exact same
thing as i stated in the academic
conference
the context in the tone in which i was
using that statement
is dramatically different
obviously in that situation where i'm
arguing with this person i'm having you
know a verbal
uh altercation with this person
i'm i'm saying that in a way to demean
that person to make it seem like
um he is inferior to me he or she is
inferior to me
and that would be inappropriate even
though i've stated the exact same words
the way in which i stated it in the
context in which i stated it
would have been inappropriate
and considered harassment
so let's go back to the apostate
prophet's comment versus
al-hakim's comment so with
the saudi scholar he was responding to a
question by one of his followers on his
own twitter page
whereas for the apostate prophet
he went to
a twitter page of a young girl a young
muslim girl who had not tagged him
who had not responded to him at all
who was just commenting on her own page
he then retweeted her comment on his
page where he has thousands of
subscribers versus her 200 or so
subscribers or followers
and then as a result of that of mocking
her
her own personal opinion on her own page
uh she was then swarmed by his you know
bigoted followers who basically you know
trash talked her and and degraded her
in other words
al-hakeem's
twitter comment was more like him being
in an academic conference
and somebody asked him a question
somebody from the audience asked him a
question and he answered with what he
considered to be a fact
whereas
in apostate prophet's circumstance
or situation
it was as though he was actively looking
for
a young lady
in her own little clique her own little
crowd
of friends
he went over snooped on her conversation
eavesdropped on her conversation
then went over told all of his friends
and then got them to basically mob this
girl
and throw all these vulgarities and
harassing comments at her
now
whether or not his comments were
actually factual is irrelevant here so
what this young girl eventually did was
she
reported his comment and then he was
suspended from twitter and i think
rightfully so
because the tone in the context in which
he made that statement was not for the
sake of educating her or simply stating
facts it was simply to embarrass her
and to make an example of her to his
followers and to feed them
like like feeding a bunch of rabid dogs
you know fresh meat that was basically
his intention and that's what it
appeared
and that's how it appeared to the
twitter moderator
um
now
after
his claim that he was just stating facts
and that he was you know just being this
innocent
this poor martyr
for free speech
he goes on to do something else that's
quite interesting what i consider to be
step two of the islamist ex-muslim
martyr syndrome
um
he goes on to state a conspiracy theory
maybe i shouldn't be surprised
considering that a major saudi prince is
a big shareholder at twitter bigger than
jack dorsey who is a co-founder of
twitter maybe this is the reason why we
see things like this maybe this is the
reason why twitter acts so unwestern so
unamerican so embarrassingly stupid and
all of this is why so many more people
are getting upset with how
the left-leaning liberal sentiment tries
to rule society with how these tech
giants that are sympathetic to those try
to make the rules for their communities
all right so there you have it
uh the apostate prophet basically states
that um
[Music]
there's a big conspiracy theory um
yeah a saudi prince apparently owns
twitter and um as a result of that
you know that's the reason he was banned
is because you know the
he the saudi prince is telling
the the ceo of twitter to send out a
memo
to all the employees at twitter telling
them you know dear employees
make sure you ban
all criticism of islam and protect the
islamists from criticism
you know protect islam
you know because you know that's what we
have to do
to save islam from all these
irrelevant keyboard warriors
um
you know signed
secret muslim
ceo of twitter
hugs and kisses
that's basically what's going on here
right now um
yeah
and it's quite ironic considering the
fact that uh
i find this really ironic considering
the fact that um
i'm sorry this is gonna get better
considering the fact that these same
ex-muslims and islamophobes love
to ridicule muslims for having very
similar conspiracy theories especially
with regard to jews
so for example i'll let the apostate
prophet speak again on this matter
it's really it's really interesting how
some people believe that a tiny minority
of people
control the entire world and are
responsible for big conspiracies a tiny
minority of people rule so many millions
of people in this world billions of
people in this world it's really amazing
i mean believing that uh that a tiny
minority of people controls the entire
world controls uh millions of people in
this world is like believing in
in magic in black magic and all those
things
uh believing in the moon landing is even
is even is even less crazy than
believing in all those jewish in all
those conspiracy theories about jews
fascinating
so
you you think that
it's ridiculous for muslims to think
that you know for example facebook is
being run by zionists
who want to stifle
uh the spread of islam
but at the same time you believe that
there's this
conspiracy theory there's this uh
you know
illuminati
shadow government
uh that aligns itself with muslims and
that's just like you know running the
world running you know making sure that
islam is being protected from criticism
these radical regressive leftist
liberals are siding with islamists you
know in their little
their little secret chambers in the
white house
or under their their corporate
headquarters and they're all just
scheming against you ex-muslims and
islamophobes you know trying to stifle
your free speech they're controlling
everything
right well i thought that was crazy
i thought it was crazy to think that a
minority of people
were controlling all these other people
hmm
interesting when it comes to you
when it comes to your conspiracy
theories that's perfectly rational it's
perfectly rational to believe that you
know a bunch of secret muslims or
radical leftists are out there just you
know making sure that they just watch
twitter and facebook all day to make
sure that islam is being protected
but then
you know when it when a muslim brings up
the jews
oh that's crazy only that's crazy right
okay
especially given the fact that uh
twitter since 2015
has banned suspended uh over 1 million
terrorist accounts especially those
coming from groups like isis
so it's interesting how you believe
that
twitter is assisting
islamists
yet at the same time they've probably
done more
than all islamophobes
and all ex-muslims combined
to fight extremism
you know as far as i'm aware i don't
even think that you've ever flagged even
one isis account
um
or any of your compatriots for that
matter
uh because
personally i think that you guys need
them
as much as they need you
you know uh without those isis accounts
you know you wouldn't have
the smarter complex you wouldn't be able
to market yourselves that well
so
you know it's fascinating how you claim
that twitter is assisting these people
when they've done so much more than
you're even capable of or even willing
to do
but you know facts who needs those right
um
so the next excuse
is is quite funny
and it kind of goes with the with the
second
stage
and that is oh you know
twitter is is stifling free speech
is cycling free speech
and um
i'll let apostate prophet speak here
again
at this point i'm really in support of
our american congress making some rules
for social media i know some might think
that twitter is a private company that
can do whatever it wants to do but
really
think about it
companies like twitter and facebook have
deliberately tried so hard to become the
norm of communication worldwide they
have tried so hard to be accepted by
major corporations by governments by the
international community
presidents have designated twitter
accounts government institutions
governments have designated twitter
accounts people are required to
communicate on twitter on facebook for
their business for their jobs for
everything these companies try to tell
you that you should come to twitter and
facebook and communicate on there but
then if you break certain rules if you
don't use the language they don't want
you to use if you say specific things
they don't like you to say then they ban
you they close the doors and say you
stay out of here and you will never come
back they exclude you from society now
how exactly is that in harmony with our
value of free speech of the first
amendment
in america we should set an example of
how freedom works of how freedom of
expression works of how we can talk to
each other how we can exchange ideas
that many people might not like without
beating each other and killing each
other something so many places in the
world cannot do but instead we have
companies we have tech giants like these
that become cowardly and tolerate
intolerance for the sake of money and
the protection of emotions this is
ridiculous
interesting view of free speech
so let me get this straight
you believe that because you were banned
from twitter for basically being a
douchebag
now
congress
the american government
should make laws
restricting twitter and other social
media platforms from banning you
let me say that again for all of you out
there who don't understand this the
apostate prophet
is arguing
that because a private company
banned him from their intellectual
property their service
that the
government should now step in
and impose upon them
laws
forcing them
to give the apostate prophet a platform
this is the exact opposite of free
speech
because part of free speech is not just
that you can say whatever you want
however you want it etc within a public
platform but it's also the right of
individuals not to listen to your
nonsense if they don't want to
and now you are
you are actively requesting
or entertaining the idea that a
government should step into a private
business
and force them
force them
to give you a platform
wow
that is amazing that's all i have to say
about that
that is amazing
and why
well let's reiterate
because the apostate prophet
was offended
that he was banned from a private
establishment
this is very similar to a recent
complaint that the explosives of north
america made when they were kicked out
of starbucks for being perceived you
know as for being perceived
as being protesters you know starbucks
didn't want them there and they kicked
them out and um
i think rightfully so by the way
and um
they had every right to do so
and yet you know these ex-muslims
complained about it they were like oh
you know they're stifling our free
expression or free speech they're you
know they were being bigoted towards
ex-muslims it's like no they weren't
they have a right as an establishment if
they perceive
that you are going to cause a ruckus or
you're going to cause a problem for
their other customers their other paying
customers and they don't want their
business to be
compromised they have a right to remove
you from the establishment
um now of course there are certain laws
in the united states that don't allow
for discrimination
and that's i think that's that's a good
thing but when it comes to speech you
know you don't just have a right to walk
into a movie theater and start shouting
at the top of your lungs and
interrupting everyone watching a movie
likewise you don't have a right to go in
and start harassing customers
you know because you think you're just
stating facts
and i just find it remarkable that you
believe that the government should have
the right
to impose laws on social media websites
to force them to give you a platform
just so you can be a douchebag
to force everyone else to listen to your
nonsense
when you don't have that right
when
free speech
the right of free speech in the united
states does not
grant you that right to invade the
privacy
of others to invade the private property
of others to
to violate
the rules of a of a business
okay you do not have that right that is
not part of your free speech rights and
if you think they are then you do not
understand free speech in the united
states
and you don't seem to respect personal
property
or the rights of gov of the rights of
businesses to dictate you know their
terms of service
you know if a business doesn't want you
to walk in with your underwear on they
have every right to to restrict your
free expression
okay
they they are allowed to do that you
know they have a right to do that to
have certain standards within their
establishment
because they're running that business
okay that is their sphere
all right and for you to suggest that
the united states government
should violate
private property
in the freedoms of
of business owners
in this regard is
is not only just absurd but it showcases
your hypocrisy
and the absolute nonsense going through
your mind
and especially ironic considering the
fact that you are constantly
you know criticizing
other governments
on the other side of the world for doing
exactly what you're trying to promote
right now
i don't know what else to say actually i
mean i'm that's really all i have to say
this video
and uh the subsequent reaction to it and
the numerous other videos and and that
follow this or that have come previously
by islamophobes and ex-muslims arguing
the exact same things making these exact
same excuses
showcases a remarkable lack of
introspection a remarkable lack of
understanding of free speech
and just just
just
such utter stupidity
um
you know what what is really going on
here
is it that
these social media websites are being
run by a bunch of
you know regressive leftist liberals
siding with islamists in this shadow
government conspiracy trying to protect
islam from criticism against these
valiant warriors of free speech and
expression in the world today full of
darkness and tyranny
or
is there a more simple explanation
maybe just maybe
that story is true maybe
or
maybe
these are just a bunch of narcissistic
irrelevant keyboard warriors trying to
compensate
for their
social and intellectual impotence
i don't know
personally as a reasonable rational
individual
i prefer the latter explanation
so let me know what you guys think in
the comment section about this whole
fiasco and and my analysis
and uh in the meantime let's enjoy the
freedom that we have to discuss these
issues at length
and to deconstruct these sort of videos
because you know eventually the apostate
prophet might actually get some laws
passed in the government that would
stifle the very free speech that he
claims to uphold
anyways thank you very much